the term PPE personal protective
equipment has been added to all of our
vocabularies it's not only essential for
healthcare workers it's now part of our
everyday lives
or at least masks are and many people
are wearing disposable gloves - problem
is they're disposable and they're ending
up in our rivers and oceans the pandemic
has created a new hazard to the
environment Redman Shannon takes a look
at how we can do better the biggest
plane in the world lands in Toronto
carrying 130 tons of medical supplies
from China including personal protective
equipment PPE is crucial for the safety
of healthcare workers dealing with Cova
19 but now all of us are consumers -
particularly for simpler or non-medical
face masks but also for gloves the
problem is not all of us are disposing
of them properly
people across the world are seeing more
and more discarded single-use PPE made
from polymers that don't decompose yet
another new source of plastic pollution
just as governments have begun tackling
the issue a group of French divers has
started digging fistfuls out of the
Mediterranean off the beautiful coked
Azur divers Yoko Peltier says people
must remember trash on the ground often
gets washed into the sea similar scenes
are visible around the globe dr. Hillary
Nash is all too familiar with ocean
plastic just before the pandemic she
traveled from England to Panama to take
part in a sailing expedition to analyze
plastic pollution in the Pacific Ocean
from that so no one around there's no
people nothing and for hours one
afternoon in that day we have constant
stream of trash just floating past our
bows it's another place unfortunately
it's another plastic plague
Nash returned at the start of the
pandemic treating covin 19 patients in
an intensive care unit she sees
discarded single-use gloves and face
masks on her short walk to work a
potential health hazard and the types of
PPE many experts say aren't really
needed for the general public for
infection control we always have even
probit and my message was always that so
we can continue to do that in health
care and protect people from infection
we need to be more mindful about the
types of plastics and the types of
Cleveland spastics that we using in
other aspects of our line Toronto
hospitals are cutting back and waste -
repurposing their respirators by
sterilizing them necessity the mother of
invention due to the strain on PPE
supply when it comes to clean hands the
public health agency of Canada says that
washing offers more protection than
wearing disposable gloves but even if
you need to wear it gloves
you still need to wash your hands anyway
or you can make a face covering out of
an old t-shirt health agencies around
the world offer tutorials on how to make
reusable washable face coverings so you
got a much better fit on the side much
better fit underneath came Troutman is
an expert on PPE standards and
certification the whole purpose of
having people wear masks at this point
now if they're just whether they be
do-it-yourself maths or the ones that we
can still purchase are for the purpose
of us not spreading the disease
Troutman says homemade masks can be
better for non medics because you can
make them to fit your face and she
recommends using more breathable natural
fabrics like a high thread-count
bedsheet why natural materials tend to
be better is they have a rougher fiber
and that rougher fiber acts and and can
catch more you know contaminants or
particles Troutman uses washable garden
gloves when shopping but insists you
need to be very careful when using a
needle
but again if you come out of any usage
with those gloves and touch any surface
you are now contaminating the surface
reusable masks could become a part of
everyday life now
so this Montreal Fashion House decided
to cater to the market
we basically recycled all the ends of
rolls that we have of all the fabrics
that we've had from previous collections
the man has been really insane actually
we are trying to keep up with demand
the high-end fashion items sell for 50
bucks but 10% of that goes to a local
women's shelter acknowledging the hidden
trauma of domestic violence in a
pandemic lockdown so we're proud to say
that it's a hundred percent made here
our martin materials are responsible and
they're easily washable than a reusable
a reminder that tackling the worldwide
problems of pandemic and pollution can
sometimes overlap with helping those
closer to home to
[Music]